times the clients that I work with and
maybe some of you have said you know I
signed up for you yeah for a new job
right now I want to enhance my skills
and I might do something with it later
on but I really signed up for a
different reason and they say so are
these resources for me and I say
absolutely they are for you so I think
that's important to know and I emphasize
that these are resources that are
provided free of no extra charge and so
you absolutely should take the
opportunity to pretend as if you were
searching for a job it's an opportunity
to dust off your resume it's an
opportunity to create a better LinkedIn
profile and maybe spend some time on
your skill gaps enhancing your portfolio
so whether you are applying for jobs
soon or not you can use these resources
they are available to you for up to one
year after graduation and I understand
that you can use them multiple times so
Angela can weigh in if that's different
that is what I learned recently when I
was out being a client absolutely and so
again as I said there's no real magic
square to begin and there's no mistakes
you cannot make a mistake but it's
important to really think about what
your goals are and I recommend a certain
order just to get started to make sure
things are in alignment okay some of the
resources that you can use we're going
to talk about the project's the LinkedIn
project Anna and the resume project but
even seeing the current coach option you
have sessions on your dashboard those
two you can use for up to one year until
graduation up to one year there are all
these sessions like what I'm doing today
are recorded and they are posted on the
YouTube channel and I think there's
another place that they're posted and
then using your network is key and
you're going to see that I hi like that
is one of the very important key things
that you should focus on even if you're
not comfortable with that so you know
there are so many things and I'm sure I
haven't listed all of them and and but I
know okay
so near narrowing your ideal company and
job that's really important to do on the
front end networking is one of those
things it's key to getting job referrals
you have an opportunity as you meet with
people to informally practice your pitch
and getting comfortable for an interview
is another thing that you can use for
your networking because you're going to
talk about your professional experiences
with people in your network and you're
going to have therefore practice but
might come up in an interview and you'll
be able to more immediately recall some
of the things that you um you thought
about before you talked about you can
learn from others without the field of
your choice
you can talk with them about how they
got to where they are now and how they
built their skills sometimes these
people many times become your long-term
friends professional colleagues that can
last a lifetime and the other thing that
is talked about and with me or the
coaches is that you also have something
to offer others and that's something
important to members feel like one way
straight for you I want to mention that
andrian has found some great webinars
and she recently did it
harder on I think it was getting in the
networking mindset is that it Angela
yeah that's right great and if I called
you a different name sorry we have two
coaches one Andrea one Angela yeah
anyway okay all right so all right so
let's go over here alright so as you
know there is a project for everything
and these are the things I talked about
that you can use for up to one year
after graduation and you can use some
multiple times so keep that in mind
resume cover letter get hung LinkedIn
and the career coaching and the way the
career coaching works is that you can
pick the same coach each time or if
they're available or you can pick a
different coach so back into lots of
flexibility and those are half hour
sessions for you and newly talk about
whatever you need helpless sometimes um
clients want to talk about their resume
but most often we get into things that
aren't covered by a project and so
that's a way to maximize all the
resources is to use the project reviews
and then if you're really stumped on
some feedback you get back from one of
these projects then we can talk about
that in a coaching session but
oftentimes it's the other Messier things
that come up like I'm really stuck I
have a plan but I'm really struggling
moving forward and so sometimes that's
where I help my clients is okay let's
talk about what's going on for you so
any just look and take a minute and just
start to sort of look at the chat okay
something about blocking the
presentation I think most of the
questions are just kind of individual so
I'm trying to address them all I think
okay people who can see everything the
way you want to see it play around with
some of your um there should be like
some little
up there that you can change your view
okay so that's actually good that's
where I'm struggling I'm a little not
used to not seeing myself I see you have
her video so my craft is involved I
could see myself I can't see myself but
that's okay so anyway but if you notice
I'm struggling a little bit out to
what's going on for me so anyway all
right so one thing I want to tell you
that no matter where you start it is
important to get the momentum going it's
important to judge is that Newton's
first law of motion anybody know what
I'm talking about a body rest who can
finish it okay a body at rest stays at
rest and a body in motion stays in
motion
that's essentially what it is exactly so
the law of inertia so I think about that
when I think about just getting started
and you know one thing that happens to
people it's happened to me before is
sometimes getting started is the biggest
hurdle and you know we can use different
strategies these are the things that
come up and coaching yes sometimes it's
best for a person to start with
something difficult okay
one of our other coaches just put on a
webinar a few weeks ago on
procrastination let's call eat your
frogs okay in that case what that means
is you start with something difficult
eat the hardest thing eat the Frog first
right sometimes that works for people
sometimes it might work to just get
started with something easy maybe you do
a couple of easy things and then the
momentum gets going and then your new
moves off easily so it might be
different things for you at different
times so really important to pay
attention to what works for you that was
the
important thing Rodolfo says I found
very positive interacting with
recruitment agency oh great okay so
that's how you've been practicing your
networking good for you he gets here
yeah it's great feedback from them
they're usually very willing to talk to
you okay big deal all right so the other
thing I want to say about getting
started and moving forward is that it's
important to revisit we're going to talk
about your written plan but it's
important to revisit your plan
very often I would even suggest that you
revisit it daily in some fashion all
right even if all you do is take one
small step forward that really does keep
going keeps you focused another trick
that I've learned maybe others have used
this is sometimes when I'm putting off
getting started to work my plan I trick
myself I used to do this with a timer
where I said hey I'm just gonna get
started for ten minutes and I expect the
timer and I'd know that in 10 minutes I
could stop if I wanted then I had it 20
minutes and what I found over time is
that it was just getting started that
helped me the most and that timer kind
of helped kept me focused then I can
then I could actually ignore the timer
and move forward so we have someone who
popped in that maybe isn't muted if you
can please put yourself on you that'd be
great
I don't know if I can tell hi I'm
spinning here from India
oh hi Stu no thank you so much it's
great great to see you on the on the
presentation or hey can I ask you to
mute now so we can't hear the background
noise thank you so much it's great to
have you here today alright so getting
started use whatever works for you now
that I'm used to that nothing
I knew it works I don't even have to use
the timer as often but it it often helps
if you find something like that all
right okay so now we're into what you
signed up for I've sort of alluded to
this earlier that if you know I'm going
to recommend that you created a written
plan I'm not sure if you can hear me yes
hello
sorry you were frozen there for a second
okay oh yeah I think we're getting some
breaking up I'm not sure if it's your
headphones and your speaking or if it's
the the internet generally so maybe just
start over there where you just work
okay all right so it's important to
create a written plan and how is that
Angela sounds good okay but I want to
say that it's more important that you
create the type of plan that works best
for you you have some experience with
that already I'm going to suggest that
you try different things until you find
something that works
I recall years and years ago reading a
book I don't even remember the author
but the plan
it was great I got a lot of ideas but to
follow that person's plan exactly meant
I went to spend time in planning mode
and so what I did was pick and choose
the pieces of suggestion that really
worked for me and over time that I
evolved that into a planning method that
works for me and sometimes I have to
change it up but the planning method
that I recommend is that you have both
short and long term goals and that you
have a whole life approach the reality
is that we cannot separate our job
search in our career transition run the
rest of life right we have family we
have community we have fun
enjoyment we have other aspects to
what's important to us so we need to
figure out a method of integrating all
the pieces of our our whole life plan
together so that we're not just focused
on one thing and and that we have a way
to work several things at the same time
okay
all right we're going to talk about
breaking it down what's that what's that
saying how do you need them an elephant
anybody know the answer to that
come on how do you eat an elephant bite
bye-bye absolutely one bite at a time
okay so breaking it down is really key I
and I run into this often with my
students and clients is that sometimes
just the way they stick the goal either
verbally or written um suggests several
steps and therefore it can become
overwhelming to us particularly if
there's a step in there that is in
unfamiliar territory or we need some
instruction about how to do it it kind
of keeps us from moving forward on any
parts of that step so it's really
important to break it down so we're
going to talk about that okay let's talk
about SMART goals all right move this
into the next life
yeah who's I don't know if you haven't
raised a hand
raise your hand you can raise your hand
in the chat right raise your hand if
you've heard about SMART goals before Oh
Minnie yes
okay mmm 3d okay
all right if you've used them say I've
used them like I've used them in the
chat good go huh
great all right three or four people
okay so you may have something to share
with us use smart and project
yes I've used them okay so um you might
see different terms up here and I've
actually changed how I use these terms
over time and I've made them work for me
so most times when you see smart goals
S stands for specific I haven't seen
much else but I'm sure there are other
terms out there M stands for measurable
all right you can feel free to weigh in
on a chat if you've used some different
terms that work for you because it might
give others some ideas a is usually
either achievable or attainable and then
I recently ran into someone who used
relevant instead of results-oriented
and there's one other and it's not
occurring to me right now
Oh reasonable okay so again I suggest
that you pick terms that resonate with
you that help you focus okay so what I
see is simple motivating attainable
realistic and time down good excellent
okay and then so I have time oriented
all right okay so the point of this is
that when you use SMART goals you can
pick whichever terms help move you
forward because that's the whole goal of
what we're here for today is how to
create a written plan how to use it to
move yourself forward all right so I
have an of the exam or this
sample SMART goal action planning tool
that you will get for attending this
webinar we'll send it by email by took
the liberty of creating an example that
relates to a job search and so we're
gonna talk about a little bit more depth
and I think to do this I'm gonna try my
best here to share my screen and away
from the presentation hey my internet
connection is unstable so bear with me
here we can we can see your planning
till now okay yeah okay yeah okay I
guess it's part of the presentation but
we can see yeah I did it is I actually
was trying to move to my to my actual
worksheet but that's okay we'll just go
with this if you can see this so what
let's just start at the top specific
what exactly do you desire and like that
important to you that's what's really
critical here um measurable how will you
know when you've achieved the desired
outcome can you evaluate it in terms of
quality or quantity how do you know when
you've arrived that's the question
okay what will that look like when you
have achieved what you want to achieve
so those are the ways to think about
these criteria achievable is this within
your reach do you have the necessary
skills or can you build those and what
is that effort that's going to be
required to do this look like when you
compare it to the game in terms of being
realistic
all right relevant results focus
realistic if you like do the sub goals
and action steps that you've created a
line with the overall vision or related
are your goals and action steps written
with our results focused
okay really important that you have that
result in mind I've heard Angela use
this before any of you Stephen Covey
fans one of my favorite things that he
said was you begin with the end in mind
okay what does that look like at the end
the correct words when I get there what
will that look like and then time
oriented or time bound as someone said
do you have project milestones deadlines
for completion and again you can do
those however that works for you you
might decide that certain things need
day month year you might decide that
there are a month and year you're higher
level goals like your five-year goal
right here might just be a and anyway
I'm gonna live here but I do suggest
that you put in the year so like right
here it looks let me go back right here
you might say okay five years will be
2025 oh my gosh it's so far out you
might put that in there because over
time time changes right and so you'd
want to say hey when I step this forth
it was back in 2020 and look where I am
now so keep being focused on the time
okay alright so your your five-year
goals in this case I want a role that
fully utilizes my new confidence areas
and artificial intelligence by doing
more hands-on work it's important to me
to be more involved in future
technologies that's the white part right
that's why I'm doing this I want to feel
more directly connected to the future of
our world and I hear this so uh okay and
then how I know I will be there is if
I'm contributing
I'm in a role where I'm contributing
with my ideas and my strengths I can see
the impact I'm making both directly and
indirectly I'll know I'm there when I
when I look forward to going to work
everyday
I feel adequately challenged and it
feels like a stimulating work
environment interacting with others and
we're building on each other's ideas and
that's the measurement criteria this is
what it will look like when I'm there
and then in terms of a three year goal
you can have something like I will be
working at a company that has future
growth opportunities in my field that
values my skills provides great health
benefits and family flexibility okay in
this case this person you'll see when we
get down to the one-year goal you'll see
that this person may be trying a desired
job by first making the transition to a
company that has that so you can see why
the order is the way it is here they're
left there saying let me find the right
company first and then I'll move in with
my current skills and but ideally I want
to be able to move into the role that
uses my new new knowledge and skill in
artificial intelligence
one of them you can see how the
measurement criteria is written okay my
internet connection is unstable Andrea
can you Angela can you hear me
yes I can hear you okay thank you so
much
all right so you can see five year three
year one year six months again nothing
magic about this do what works for you
you might decide in a certain life area
if you are going to start with the
two-year goal alone the five-year this
is why this is customized you can use
this tool however best works for you in
most things particularly with a career
if you're going to do good career
planning you do want to thank two to
four years out three to five years but
hey if you're having trouble thinking
like that then start at three years just
start here okay one year I'm going to be
in full job search mode I'll be
interviewing evaluating not oh it's uh
uh how expand
my network I might still be in my
current role but I'm looking toward the
future for my career change okay so I
usually start up here quite honestly
because that's that begin with the end
in mind approach okay yeah it's usually
better to think out further and then
back into okay what's reasonable and
unrealistic done in three years but one
year and then the six-month goal here
could be hey I'm just going to finish
some yellow degree and I'm going to
graduate by April of 2020 right okay you
with me so far but I smoke my work you
are interacting with okay great it can
be a great source of advice yeah Rodolfo
thank you
very good all right so now I want to
show you before we move on um how to
write the tactics and objectives okay
sorry bear with me guys okay so and this
only shows a partial list you will see
on the tool I'm going to send you that
you could have pages and pages of action
tactics and you probably will lotta time
you're all through break it down as I
said earlier small bites okay in order
to complete the degree it's required
that I do the github so I need to make
sure I fully utilize that option and go
through the review process that's one
step in the right direction and I'm
going to assign it a due date right here
and in this case because it is something
that is more pressing and eminent it may
help me to say what day month and year
I'm not gonna have this done by that
doesn't mean it cannot change you might
decide hey I want to stay true I want to
hold myself
Hannibal to the plan but I can be a
little bit flexible I know that
essentially I've made progress and so if
I miss it by a week or a few days or
maybe even two weeks the point is that I
finished there's another step I'm gonna
get the feedback okay because that's
gonna happen a different time frame
that's why it's important not to group
these things at least for most of us if
you want to agree that that's up to you
but in order to really think about the
steps and make sure that you've outlined
everything it's important to break it
down the other step could be make sure
my profile is professional for talent
hub access by employers okay different
the product job search one of the things
I'm going to focus on is my job search
and so to get moving in that direction
I'm going to start watching two Udacity
career webinars per week the pre record
the recorded sessions and I'm going to
start that today and it's going to be
ongoing all right all right so any
questions so far
[Music]
okay so I set this a little bit before
but again make this tool work for you
and pay attention to what's working and
what's not working okay it's okay if you
struggle struggles where we grow and
learn so I'll feel bad about that and
just you know kind of revisit it if
you're out what what worked for you the
last time and in fact I recommend you do
that before you even work with this tool
if you decide to work with this tool
think about okay what kind of planning
method has worked for me in the past and
what did I do
did I write it down did I not run it
down how much detail that I get into did
I have dates how detailed where the
plans asking yourself those questions
will really help you realize what works
for you and what doesn't work so and
then be it don't be afraid to try
something new
alright now you do need to make sure
that your short-term plan is aligned
with your long-term goals so blank yeah
Peter look writing down your action
steps you need to go back up and
evaluate okay just this align is it
relevant to my my five year goal if I
move in this direction I get this done
how does it help me get there okay you
know here's an example if if you maybe
we can work through this one if you're
going to be making a healthy nutritious
dinner at home tonight what would it be
one step in alignment with that goal
let's here in the check what would be
something you'd do if you were going to
make a healthy nutritious dinner at home
tonight we're just using this simple
example yeah
get out the recipe excellent Cyndi
perfect get the ingredients on the
recipe yeah this actually is even
getting out the recipe is what I call
staging things I think we're going to
talk about that in one of the slides or
maybe it was on it or
there's flight so staging things get
ready to make progress all right grocery
shopping yes you might have to grocery
shot okay one thing that might not be
directional feed dinner oh delegating
the cookie with someone else I love it
great Angela all right one thing that
might be counter to that plan is leaving
in the afternoon and staying out till
all hours of the night and not even
thinking about dinner though that might
be counter to the plan right could be
some other things or going to fast food
and eating nothing afternoon that might
be counter to having a healthy cooking a
healthy dinner when you get along you're
not hungry and you just have junk junk
food so you really didn't accomplish
your healthy eating at home plan right
anyway some laughter going on in the
chat thank you for that all right so one
other thing I want to say on this is
don't worry about creating a long plan
when you sit down with this tool or any
other tool you don't have to have
everything figured out right now it does
make sense to get this area this area
right here done as much as possible
but you don't have to have all the
action steps in fact I would suggest you
not do that because it may not be clear
to you exactly what you need to do to
move forward at that point in time go
ahead and outline things that make sense
maybe plan for two and if you're not
sure when you need to do something or
whatever but you want to list it go
ahead and list it in one of the rows
here down get it on there but you can
come back and change it later okay and
it really doesn't matter that it's
pretty unless that's important to you
maybe having it organized so you can
read it many of my clients fill these
out
um you know pen to paper and that works
for them and that's all I care about is
if they can read it and that works for
them and it's easy for them to update
and cross off and check check off so
those are just some suggestions as you
work on your plan and then once you find
a method that works for you use it for
multiple areas of your life okay you
might have some family goals or some
community engagement goals that you want
to work on and so right up here in the
category section this might be you know
family time or a family enhancement you
might be working on a plan to get deeper
engagement within your family and so
what does that look like to you
okay that's good practice all right okay
one of the important things that you'll
need to do and whether you write plans
for different areas of your life I
wouldn't necessarily suggest and write
them for all areas but if there are
particular things you want to do to make
change you could have two or three like
plans going at the same time you could
have a family plan you might have a
spiritual plan and so integrating those
together on a weekly or daily basis is
very important okay so how you do that
can be tricky all right so we can talk
about the details on that
all right right and
is a place to use the Udacity career
coaches you've written your plan or
you're struggling moving forward you
found the stumbling blocks that you know
sometimes I don't know if you saw the
moving forward career tips and the
careers Channel last week that I did but
uncertainty is an area that sometimes
that's this cold in our tracks we're not
quite sure how to do something and so we
get you know we're stuck so if you need
help with that um you should definitely
get some help with that or maybe your
plans not working maybe another coach
can help you with that
and generate some thinking around that
and help you figure out how to move
forward okay all right so now you've
written a plan um here's how to work
your plan okay it's really important and
it's a cycle as depicted in the picture
that I have out there there are all
kinds of think plan do and act in this
case it's a plan check and repeat and I
would say the repeat thing is very
important here as well okay you need to
revisit your plan often you need to
adjust it as needed a change in left we
have unexpected things come up um I've
got another unstable message here Angela
can you hear me yeah we can hear you it
just kind of breaks up and crackles a
little bit but you seem to keep coming
back Don okay okay great
sorry hey I'm Justin as needed I
recommend you don't adjust just because
you didn't meet your goal if that's
what's at the core of adjusting now you
might say okay well I didn't get this
done but so I'm going to give myself a
new deadline but think about what you
need to do differently in order to meet
the deadlines this time think about why
it didn't happen as planned
sometimes those circumstances you're
outside of your control very often
that's the case
so don't give up but sometimes
circumstances change or you learn
something new that needs to be factored
in so feel free to make adjustments to
plan build in that accountability for
yourself find accountability partners if
needed so I'm going to talk about your
plan with you know somebody would be
accountable for say you know to one of
your colleagues hey I'm working on this
and would you be my accountability
partner I this is my plan I'm gonna do
this by this time could we you know I
would love some support let's talk about
what that means maybe it's a text second
date and say how it's going so anyway
these are all things be creative with
this and then as Cindy pointed out in
our example about making a healthy
dinner tonight
staging next steps so important it helps
you move forward when you know you need
to do make dinner let's just use that
one it's moving in the right direction
to actually get out the recipe go out on
Pinterest and find the recipe whatever
it is doing one step in the right
direction can make all the difference
whether you complete something or not
and how quickly it takes you or how
quickly it goes um think about your
productive Peaks what's the best time of
day or night when do you get the most
done on that sort of task very important
to think about what's conducive to being
successful and moving for early risers
the computer work we have to do goes
well and first thing in the morning and
not so well after we're tired at the end
of the day so think about the type of
task that you want to do and what would
be helpful in terms of time of day and
then as far as integrating with the
other plans um I want to show you a
couple of ways to do that too life plans
let's say you have one on job searching
you have one on let's say family
right so they're two separate plans you
want to make sure you have a method of
integrating the next steps on those two
plans and you can use whatever method
works for you this is actually Angela
can you see this I can't see myself so
um can you raise it up a little higher a
little bit lower lower a little closer
to you back up a little okay yeah a
little bit okay well I guess what it is
use post-it notes um you can create a
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday with post-it notes um
with the short-term steps and lay them
onto your plan and you can create boats
were both life plans so on Monday I am
going to look into github and what I
need to do as the next step and also on
Monday I'm going to reach out to my
daughter and check in with her and see
how her college life is going okay you
can see those are two different life
areas but I'm going to do those things
on Monday um there's another you know
you can buy something I have something
if you can see it but I bought this at
Office Max it is a weekly plan sheet
there's a bunch of them I tear them off
and it has them week at the top and it
has Monday Tuesday all the way through
Sunday that has a to-do list on the far
right and a place for notes and it was
really inexpensive and I didn't have to
spend time on creating that so it helps
me I have my major goal planning sheets
and I use that to make sure that I'm
moving forward on something I plan every
week and sometimes every day okay so
those are ways you can integrate two
different plans and then most
importantly pat yourself on the back
when you have success
okay when you are making forward
progress don't wait till the end but
when you're making progress you want to
give yourself some support you've got
one step in the right direction
sometimes that's a monumental task
depending on what the step is so all
right well we are almost at the end of
the session and I'd love to hear from
some of you if there's something you
would like to interject to the
conversation or if you have questions
we'll take the next ten minutes to
answer
[Music]
Diane yeah a couple things I think that
we're kind of being discussed and
touched on a little in the chat that you
might want to clarify is the sharing of
those goals and and one comment I made
on there was it some of those goals you
might decide are just your very personal
private goals and other goals you might
discuss with a recruiter you might
discuss with a interviewer but clearly
some of our goals aren't what we want to
share with a recruiter obviously if we
want to start our own business in five
years but we're interviewing for a job
that may be something we keep to
ourselves and maybe I want to talk a
little bit about how that how you can
you know that doesn't have to be an open
book I guess yeah and that I guess I and
it's sharing I at least for me my goals
are generally pretty private
I might when I met when I said sharing
with your colleague in your network yeah
you'd want to be very selective about
certain things um these are really
intended for you it doesn't mean as
Angela said that you it might not come
up if a recruiter ask you what you're
you know where do you see yourself in
five years you want to have that answer
actually thought through practiced and
comfortable in terms of the way planet
do in it might look different than what
is or slightly different than what you
say it then what's on your your goal
sheet but really these plans are for you
and I would be selective about who you
share with and why you're I was just ask
yourself I have I think very helpful is
to get support certainly with your coach
you could share here's here you know
here's my one year goal and I'm
struggling
I need help breaking this down or I
don't even know where to start
that's a good example of where you might
want to share when you're
meeting with a colleague certainly there
might be something on your goal sheet
that you want to share so I hope that
helps but um I don't think it's intended
you certainly me
you know Michael people in an interview
or anything like that I would just want
to be thoughtful about what in my clan
should be shared and how do I want to
share okay okay all right any questions
for the whole group or for me or
thoughts it's been great having you on
here today I'm going to get you the the
planning spreadsheet I'll try to send
you one that is have both the samples so
you can see how I formulated some of the
parts of that and then I'll send you a
blank so it's easy and again play around
with it if you don't like the columns of
the both the headings or the
nomenclature that's used for this you
know fix it make it make it work for you
and yes there should be a recorded
version of this that will be sent out
later and in the YouTube channel so I
cannot say exactly if someone else when
did we get the goal sheet I'm going to
send it today to the career
administration they can get it out as
soon as possible but I'm not exactly
sure when it will go out all right okay
okay well thank you again for for
joining me today I'm a up I can stay on
for the next five minutes if anyone has
anything else they want to share
make because their boss
you should I'm sorry um Jackie I think
you're speaking and I can't make out
what you're saying it's probably on my
end
are you able to type your thought or a
question in the chat please yeah it was
hard for me to it was breaking up a lot
so if he could type it I think I don't
think it was just your end oh you're
very welcome thank you all for your
comments
you're welcome I've enjoyed this today
sorry is a little rusty in certain
places here it'll get better I promise
alright Johnny key you want to try again
oh thank you my okay
all right thank you all so much
will will drop off now I think I think
everyone's had an opportunity to ask
their questions and I encourage you to
schedule a session with a career coach
and them and get started thank you have
a great day great rest of the day thank
you all bye bye